welcome to quarter cast are you taking
the intro
episode 94 and uh we're going to start
off with a little uh
music trivia quiz can anyone scoot
boogie
yeah anyone can anyone guess the song in
particular wren can you guess the song
ready
one two three go
[Music]
yes mario super nintendo yes mario right
[Laughter]
see what you're talking about now yeah i
don't know how to play a talk at all i
i don't either like i know the know what
i know when the notes go up and down
yeah but that's about it wait so were
you intending to play that or was that
like a psych experiment on just
hearing a song no i every note was we
were both making it up 100
we neither of us studied the song that's
a really fascinating exercise though
because it's like the notes literally
don't matter it's just the
change between notes that matters so as
long as you know how to go up and down
on the scale it's like it works yeah i
can play so many songs on guitar now
that i've mastered the technique of not
caring about notes
i mean this is darth vader's theme
[Laughter]
have you ever played guitar before play
me a popular song
jeez i do i do not play guitar it's even
better if you don't
tell us what the song is going to be
yeah i
okay what's high that's okay okay i have
tyler okay
uh i don't know a song i'm on the spot
friend think of a song
any song just name it okay no i got it
ready wait wait stop playing
[Music]
jake's just playing a nice actual song
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
we solved it we solved how you can play
any song
dude guys welcome to our master class
any instrument
as long as you play the notes in time
you will have a great time and everyone
will be able to recognize what you're
playing
see people you're a good musician and
people know what song you're playing
that's the key
yep yeah and solo it's all it's about
that's all it's about
it's amazing yeah so that's that you try
and take
any deep thoughts you want out of that
experiment but that was just for a laugh
yeah so what are we doing this week boys
we're back from memorial day
oh that's good yeah i'm uh i'm working
on
ai based uh age uh okay
or face augmentation can i show a photo
that i found
sure that you found can we can we show
it to the tree you'll have to describe
it for the people that are listening to
this audio only which is this is
the best way to watch a podcast this is
a photo of me
from i don't know maybe second or third
grade
okay ready for this yeah um should i not
be
look at that hey it's a young jake wow
that's
it hold it closer to your face what's in
focus
you look like a kid who would get in
fights with the teacher
is it the rat can you see the rat tail
what no
do you notice that no i thought that was
a shadow peeking out that's why
spencer and i were kindred from the
moment of birth
because we both had rat tails i also
found this hilarious
uh 90s family photo
whoa wow composing which is it's so 90s
it's not even funny
like the the color the color
coordination geometric layout
the perfect symmetry yeah it's
these are so funny they were i went back
through and found a couple good ones for
you so you can uh
you can get a good one for me yeah so so
jake's looking for photos of himself as
a child
because i requested that from every
person in the office i recently got so
my dad like a year or two ago
went through and scanned all of our old
family photos yeah
like he like growing up he would just be
taking photos all the time and they
would come out on like those little like
rolls
those stacks of uh was it like 99 minute
photo 60 minute photo yeah yeah 99
minutes
one hour photo one hour and 29 minute
photo
they just start a bunch of different
llc's to accommodate for
the different time it takes
wait did you guys see that robin
williams movie one hour photo yeah that
was a weird one that was a good one
sorry continue yeah uh what was i
talking about
so uh like we ended up with like shoe
boxes filled with like those little
packets full of photos
and he went through and he scanned all
of them and he gave my sister and i like
like a
20 gigs worth of just scans so i have
like i've gone through
like a bunch of them and it's it's kind
of crazy just going down memory lane
like that
it's like wow yeah my my uh has tasked
me
with i actually had to buy a photo
scanner the other day i haven't unboxed
it
my aunt started sending me photo books
oh and she's like you need to scan these
because no one else is gonna
listen now so now i'm that guy no
the responsibility is falling onto you
yeah but i bought a decent photo scanner
so i'm kind of excited about it so
what you're saying is you're never too
old for nephew duties no
certainly yeah as long as you have an
ant
no i need muzzle flashes in this video
yeah
exactly yeah my mother-in-law for her
birthday got uh from her daughter's
uh a service that will digitize vhs
tapes
so you basically just they send you a
box and you fill the box up with all
your vhs tapes
and you send it back and then they
return that box to you with a drive
filled with uh digital files um that was
another thing i had a bunch growing up
like vhs
classic home videos i had them
transferred to dv tape that's as far as
i got
okay so wren what was the craziest thing
uh what was the best family photo and
the worst family photo wait real quick
should we mention why we're talking
about pictures of us as kids
in a moment yeah we'll get there it's a
podcast
uh i think my favorite family photos i
mean we didn't really have many
family photos quote unquote it would be
like us
out in the wilderness
my dad would set up a camera we'd stand
in front of it because we're like
camping or something uh
yeah my favorite family photos are the
karate photos oh yeah those are really
good
no i guess specifically for my was
taekwondo is my dad my sister and i
there's one i remember you i saw i saw
some of this
there's a few words like my dad would
like be like looking stern over the two
of us
my sister would be doing the splits or
i'd be doing the splits one of us we do
on punch or something
you know it's weird goofy stuff like
that and then there's this one photo of
me where i'm doing a jumping front kick
over a wolf and i'm just doing a front
kick over but i'm making this face
an actual wolf no it was like you know
they they put in
you you're like filmed on a blue screen
or whatever and they replace the
background
this is before i even really understood
what any of that even meant
i got into effects kind of late in life
that's amazing i know it's like the most
like it's the epitome of the like the
mid to late 90s
like action photo yeah yeah
it's like i for some reason remember
seeing lasers in them
but i don't know if there were lasers
but yeah i remember they're being lasers
too but i don't think there were were
there
probably no lasers there should have
been should have been yeah
yeah a quintessential laser backdrop
yeah yeah you guys have a crazy family
photo
no crazy family photos no i mean i've
got i've got one where
my my sister and my two brothers and me
my mom made us all put on our letter
jackets
and stan stand on the stairwell
like like this with all of our years
and my sister was out of high school at
this point she was like two years out so
that was considered
totally not cool and my mom made her do
it anyway she was so and you can tell in
the photo that she's not
happy about it wow oh man
yeah it's glad you took that picture now
all my uh
family photos from like 1999
and on were basically like my mom
got into portrait photography so she
insisted in
basically setting up and taking all of
them herself so like the photos
generally look pretty nice actually but
like everyone looks super dopey because
it's kind of like the everyone dresses
themselves thing like she's great at the
photo end but
do you remember that see that uh scene
you have a viewing like the
blue velvet jacket in the uzi yeah i'm
like yeah
she's like i want to take portraits of
you i'm like i've got this airsoft gun i
want to post
we said this is a screensaver on a
computer we should do this again soon at
least one of the computers in here but
it's just sam different poses like nice
portrait lighting
with a blue velvet jacket and a newsy
looking really classy yeah well your mom
had a studio in your house sam
yeah yeah exactly yeah hence the our
founders photo
that's the our founders photo yeah yeah
oh that's where that came from yeah
right
okay yep yeah
i mean both of them the the original one
where we have where nico has the bandana
what was it the sidewinder
yes sidewinder and mecha force yeah when
you got the bandana
and stuff and we're all like like hip
dude yeah i got my dragon like button up
shirt yeah
your dragon button oh yeah yeah you
can't find these anywhere
i had to kill a guy to get this
i distinctly remember that uh bandana
though that blue bandana
i do have one more uh founder photo
that's a different version
i can't remember if i brought her now
might be sitting my desk at home but
yeah
similar back in the day when sam are
making a bunch of goofy action films in
high school
and a lot of cops so why are we doing
this niko oh yeah
so there's uh there's a bunch of like
really cool experiments
happening in like the style gan uh like
ai space so you've probably seen like
you may have seen on the unit like this
isn't a real face and it's like a
totally real looking picture of
someone's face
and it's you know they'll show a video
of like you know morphing between
different faces and basically their ai
generated faces
and that in the video yeah yeah in the
video what was the name of that video
that was the uh
you monster oh right right all the
instagram profiles i
i literally generated people is like the
website this person is not real.com yeah
you just refresh it a brand new photo
comes up and it's like this person is
not real it's just a generated photo
i think tell me if this person does not
exist
yeah yeah uh but if you haven't been
there it's interesting you might be like
they're competing they're competing
sites they're they're competing for this
yeah yeah
and if you go there like these are
totally real people what what what's
going on here and
basically it's you know there's uh so
this is data set of
of pictures that uh nvidia made called
the ffhq
full face high quality i believe it was
is what it stands for wait yeah i know
i've heard about that yeah
and so basically it's like it's like uh
it's like
70 000 pictures or 60 000 pictures
that's right no i remember you tell me
about it when we were doing the
skywalker deep fake yep yeah so
basically nvidia
you know in terms of training things
like so there's a thing called a again a
generator
generative adversarial network um and
said style of ai
long story short it lets you it lets you
feed
images to it and then it can generate
approximations of those images
it's it can only do it if you like you
categorize it so you can feed it like
you know 50 000 faces and be like
generate me a face
and basically it's basically a collage
it's going to go through and like
pull on like all the little bits of
everything from all the faces just to
generate a new random face
um or you can show it you know 50 000
pictures of cars and have it generate
you a car
um that kind of seems pretty sweet it is
really sweet it's really cool
i want to see like a car that doesn't
exist yeah
but in a way it's a little underwhelming
because it's not that it doesn't exist
because it is actually a subset of all
the other cars it's not like it's going
to invent
a style of car that it hasn't seen
before you know it's only going to be
blends
of what's already there same thing with
the faces well that goes back to like i
feel like all of the ai
machine learning stuff in general is
like you can never get
what it hasn't trained on yeah you can
never get something that you didn't
put in to begin with yeah or if you do
it's not like it's not in the sense of
like uh it's these
so we start defining like really
interesting concepts here as you start
talking about this stuff but like
like you can get ai to generate
something it hasn't seen before but it's
going to be
a subset or influenced by what it has
seen right
yeah you know versus like a totally
random new thing i believe one of the
terms for uh like defects is like
hallucination
when a computer is trying to draw
something that it doesn't know what it
is it's hallucinating and interesting
which is a cool term for it um see this
is like this we get to get into all
these cool like
cyberpunk terms it's totally a frontier
you can call things whatever you want
right now
this computer's this computer is
hallucinating someone stop it
exactly uh so anyways uh so you know
with uh stylegan you can create this but
then you can also
you can manipulate things in a really
interesting way so when you're dealing
with a picture of a human face
in this like in this game space ai space
um you know it's not like there's
it's not like in the classic bitmap
sense it's more like in terms of
features like there's
roughly like parts of the ai that get
triggered when they see eyebrows there's
parts of the ai that get triggered when
they see mouths as parts
yeah they get triggered with different
skin tones and different lighting so
kind of like i don't know if you've ever
seen like uh like brain scans like when
people like look at a picture or a word
like parts of the brain light up
yeah you look at a picture of a bird and
different parts of the you know brain
light up but they look at the word bird
and like in this overlap you know
um it's it's a similar thing for neural
networks because they're kind of based
on that philosophy of neurons
and you know so different like you know
areas of these neural networks get
activated and they see
like these different features or when
you're drawing these different features
so people you know they're taking this
research and they're rolling that ball
even further
so then they got to the point was like
well what if like i want to load a new
picture of a face what if i want to take
a picture of ren
and move it into this latent space of
this
of this ai right because it's these
aren't bitmaps that you're looking at
they're they're generative pictures you
know they're little bits of neurons
being activated to draw certain eyes and
faces and things like that
um so some programs came out that
basically would let you take a picture
of somebody
and then try to get as close as you
could to triggering the right neurons to
generate that face
in the ai space oh and
once you've done that now you have the
not a jpeg or a png
the raw data you have the ingredients
the neural network activation
pattern
[Laughter]
and the thing is like it doesn't woman
in the red dress it rarely looks perfect
it's always like a weird approximation
it's like
and you can see like hints of
celebrities because a lot of these faces
are celebrities like ooh
like those are slightly michael sarah's
eyes and i'm looking at ren's victory
that'll be me
yeah here we go again
i'm gonna give that to you and it's just
gonna give you an image of christian
bale
here yeah man i've already seen hints of
george clooney and some faces too it's
like
it pops up um but the cool thing is then
you can take some of these parameters
and be like well i'm going to say select
the the neurons that are triggered with
hair and then i'm going to start
pushing these in different ways and
sometimes it changes the hair color
or sometimes it changes the hairstyle
because it starts pulling from other
hair colors or hairstyles it's seen on
other faces
and so you're moving through that that
space that that latent space
of face data basically or the of that
way are you seeing like an animation
is that you can make an animation but
more so it's like the results you're
getting out of it
so once you've been able to transfer a
face out of just being a picture and
into this like you know like you said
the raw data you're in the neural
network
um you can change parameters of that
face
and unlike photoshop where you're
working on a pixel level
in this in this you know ai space in
this neural space you're working in the
neural level so
you can it's like going into somebody's
brain and like you know like you know
when like people like are you doing
brain surgery and like
the doctors poking part of their brain
the person oh yeah i know i taste like
alkaline or like oh right i feel sad i
actually have heard of that before yeah
yeah where yeah you trigger some weird
sense mm-hmm
like you yeah like a taste by like
poking the right part of the brain
so so you push this network in certain
ways and you can take this picture of a
face and then you can evolve it by
pushing it towards the other faces and
like i said you know the things are
triggered when you look at a wrinkly
face versus a smooth face you can find
what's had doing that in the neural
network
and you can activate those and something
you can put wrinkles on your face
except it looks really really
photorealistic because it's being
rendered in this hyper-realistic
like face generation thing so what what
is
what is the purpose behind what you're
doing so we decided to do an experiment
because you can age up and you can age
down photos you can change their genders
you can do pretty much anything
um as long as you're just pushing to
like other spaces in this
in this neural space that's called a
latent space it's technically the term
for it but
we want to experiment where you know can
and ai predict the future so to speak
can it predict the past can i feed an ai
a picture
of us as kids and then use the ai to age
our faces up using this new method
and how accurate it is is it to what our
faces would actually look like if
they're aged up now how
how does this compare to like say the
face app remember like was that last
year the year before when you like
literally just snap on our phone would
like look at our face and then make us
look old
face up i mean face app was actually
super cool
um and it works in many similar ways so
i think that one was
more of like a it's hard to say because
i don't exactly know how it worked but i
think that was more of a style transfer
that's where it's like it's more of a
textural change
and while you can certainly do textural
changes here here
this i like i'm curious because this is
what we're finding out this we're making
a crew video about this and this is what
the experiment really is
is delving into is when you're doing it
through
this style of an ai when it's seen old
faces and young faces and it's ha
it has all these faces basically mapped
to this latent space
when you trigger the things that make it
you know the triggers that make a face
old when you trigger those wrinkle
sensors
and whatever else you know who you know
who knows whatever else it is that
activates when you see an old face
does that give you a more accurate
representation of what you would
actually look like when you're old
versus say doing like the face app
method of just like a style swap or like
you know a texture swap
um okay okay you know and you should
compare those
we should and yeah it's like part of it
like uh the face app when you put it on
a baby it just looks like an
old baby yeah benjamin button as opposed
to like actually what they would look
like as an older person
yeah and i'm oversimplifying what face
app does like face app is actually
pretty sophisticated too right
but this is just this is a different
thing and you can push it in more than
just
age you can push it anywhere you can
there's new like and this is i'm
stepping out of my
knowledge base here but like there's new
ways to manipulate these spaces
uh and what i'm using right now is style
clip when clip is a totally different ai
model clip
clip yeah clip clip which i think
believe is made by open ai the same
people
not to be confused with the other ai
called mag
[Laughter]
a clip is when the faces are all bound
together through a
through an actual clip and a and mag is
when the faces are stacked together
inside of a compartment
[Laughter]
so uh the company behind gpt3 which if
you've listened to this podcast
recently we did a bunch of gp23 stuff
recently um
they also made this thing called clip i
think it was them
um and clip is basically a like a
judgment ai
yeah what kind of judgment are we
talking like judgment he showed a
picture he goes that's a real picture or
that's not a real picture
okay which is really handy when you're
actually training other ais
because you can use clip as a judgment
portion of this
to like you know inform things so you
know by messing with the system you know
right now you can you can alter anything
it doesn't just have to be
age it can be literally your hairstyle
it can be your facial hair
it can be your gender you can literally
write cartoon characters and i'll start
warping your features your face the
magic cartoon character
um you know and there's limits because
once again it's only been trained on the
set
of faces you know that it's seen so
it can only go so far um but you can
do a lot of really interesting stuff
with it so the big experiment right now
is like if i take a picture of one of us
as a kid
and i age it up using the ai how
accurate is it and vice versa
currently finding that it's it's 50 50
but it's giving me a lot of really
interesting results in the process
like the the style clip method
you know if you think of it like a
filter like you're just working some
sliders you have like a strength slider
right
but then you have one which is the
number of like neurons to activate
so you can i'm just like threshold type
deal yeah so it's like
for example i can be like just activate
the couple of parameters that are
specifically identified say with eye
color
if i'm changing my eye color right okay
sure and maybe i only have
like just like one or two or three
parameters but i can start to expand it
to 10 15 20
100 200 and it starts to bring in other
things that are associated with eye
color like hair color
or face structure or makeup you know so
as you expand this you can start to lose
the likeness of the person you're
working with
but you also start to see like these
other attributes that kind of go hand in
hand with things and it's one of the
reasons like a lot of filters can look
weird like photoshop's smile filter
right
if the wrinkles around the outside your
eyes don't change when your smile
changes
this red is demonstrating now it doesn't
look right you know and so if your
parameters are too small you can move
just lip so that nothing else changes on
the face and it looks weird
or you know or you change too much and
you've totally changed into a different
person
um it's really fascinating stuff and i
think a brand new
you yeah and that's just what we're
working on uh that's what i've been
working on recently it'll be out in the
quarter crew channel probably in
about two weeks yeah okay that's the end
of my feel that's the end of what i'm
working on
sam ren yeah that's really exciting can
we
can we take like um like
abraham lincoln or something and see
what they would look like today
if they just kept aging you could do
that you could also
the other really cool thing about this
is you can take a picture that's not
necessarily a photo
like the painting of the mona lisa and
then find
the nearest equivalent in this uh
style gan space it'll be a real person's
you know collage or more or less
real people's features finding the actor
that played the mona lisa exactly
you know and then it'll it'll tell you
if she's smirking
or if she's sad
yeah it's true because no one knows it's
up to you man what do you think okay
i mean i think she's kind of smirking i
i don't know then that's the truth that
you live by
okay i think she's smirking at life you
know she knows it's all
it's all just fleeting yeah
is it her or is it da vinci smirking at
life yeah
yeah exactly yeah
yeah i know i gotta get all these kid
pictures i'm like i don't even know what
to do
i got somewhere on my phone i think just
gotta keep scrolling
you just need one i know i know the one
it's it's like a second grade straight
on the camera you got this
super doofy smile it's great perfect
when i was a kid i had a totally
different smile too like i smiled
differently i was like
your bottom lip covered up your top lip
yeah i was like are your top teeth
something like that i didn't know how to
smile you know
that's what that's i feel like half the
reason why like kid photos
uh specifically like yearbook photos you
know when you show up at school just all
night you take your photo it's like
kids at that age don't know how to
actually smile
yeah like intentionally consciously yeah
consciously exactly it's like
all kids will smile when they're when
they're happy and are smiling but like
like oh you want me to smile now i'm
very nervous there's a lot of lights
pointed at me at my teeth
i am still wearing a police uniform
did you join the phone did you join the
force red what happened mama rookie what
are you guys filming
terminator 2 oh you're getting the shots
yeah nice we got the shots today how is
that going
ah it's going there is a an exhibit at
the science museum
in minnesota back when i was like 10
years old and it was a visual effects
and special effects exhibit
it was super rad cool and one of the
segments was on t2
and how they did the the bar like
molding through the bars and stuff
that's like literally what we're doing
oh it's a deep dive into that shot
wait tell us how they did it because we
really like those this is kind of like
the foundation of the videos how did
they do this
oh yeah we've we've found the research
that points us in the pretty good
direction but
i vaguely remember it so remember
there's like a you know vhs playing on
some tv
as long as you see him i remember them
making a 3d model and roughly tracking
it to his head and building bars and
having something that would deform the
3d model as it moved through the bars
and then i don't know if they texture
projected mapped his face
onto the head or if they just simply
used it for shading and kind of called
it a day but that's all i really
remember
i mean that was basically it they
invented
projection mapping for that shot for
that one shot damn
they they created a program to basically
stick a texture onto a 3d model and they
use the texture
from the camera of the dude walking
through uh and it's it's really crazy to
read the interview about them talking
about that because
he's literally describing not just
camera mapping but
uvw maps oh wow and it was a brand new
concept of having like
a texture coordinate stick to a geometry
coordinate that's so cool
and the software they had at the time
was called make sticky
sticky that was what they called us like
we're gonna use make sticky
and uh we're gonna to make the texture
stick to the yeah
yeah and that was the second name the
first name was called
make me sticky and
that one that's a name that didn't stick
people didn't like it
oh my god like i don't want to have to
say this ever sticky
don't go to makemesticky.com you'll
probably get something
scary yeah don't yeah that's wild yeah
no it's and it's super cool because it's
like
yeah so part of this video we're doing
is basically a deep dive investigation
into
how they did some of these effects from
terminator 2 which came out in 1991 30
years ago this july
and wow uh part of that is kind of us
just kind of
going into it another part of it is
peter and i trying to
take a couple different methods of
recreating one of those shots like with
modern
uh tools and whatnot and what kind of
challenges aren't really a thing anymore
what challenges are now a thing that
weren't back then what sort of
challenges persist through time
um and hopefully ideally if it works out
we'll actually get to interview
uh someone who worked on one of those
shots which i have lead on
that'd be really cool yeah i dm'd a
message to someone may have gotten a hit
but we might have to actually work
directly with island pr
so we'll see you guys all saw the uh
the captain disillusion flight of the
navigator video right i honestly haven't
finished
it i i sat down to watch it thinking it
was like gonna be like a good like 5-10
minute video that video was 41 minutes
long
and i was just like oh i don't have time
to finish this and then it's just one of
those that i i
haven't gotten back to i mean too it's
so well made though like
yeah classic captain d i wish there was
a tv
i wish he could do that for like you
know 15 episodes and just like
capture the magic of like old films like
that yeah and you know and that's the
thing is that like people would watch it
there would absolutely be an audience
for it but
you know it's the same problem that ian
hubert has where it's like you have one
guy
doing everything and
you know it's like okay well get a team
to help you and then you can do more of
it and you know
throw a bunch of money and budget at the
problem and like you can do more of that
and it's like well
the more you do that though then the
less you know captain disillusion the
less ian hubert is directly involved
with that stuff and then it kind of
becomes
less of be making it yeah
the one guy running the team as opposed
to the one guy making it did you catch
the the
captain disillusion did the voice of
that character in ian's short
i missed it i heard about it i have yeah
the little floating robot
thing that's talking and going around oh
he did that's oh that's happening
yeah yeah yeah he voiced that like which
is like the only other character that
speaks
that's awesome yeah i it was one of
those one i found out about i was like
how did i not notice that
yeah i should have known that i know
yeah clint said he did some
voice over for it too he did i think he
did a little bit of like some background
talking
okay i don't think there's any like
direct like on camera talking yeah
is people the other little robot that
goes by or like get out of the way
like i don't know oh yeah that's funny
how a feeling it is
it sounds a lot like him that's really
funny i would be surprised if it is i
keep forgetting
is it allen is that his real name alan
yeah okay i know it's also his interns
names i didn't want like in
character so i didn't want to like
call him by his own character in turn's
name but calling him captain disillusion
as we keep talking about himself i know
yeah right
yeah i mean uh allen's a good voice
actor like
that i mean we should transition to talk
about ian's video too because holy moly
yeah right yeah my god yeah that was
incredible
like i've i can't remember who described
it as miyazaki in real life or not real
life
yeah ghibli yeah yeah yeah it felt like
that
it's definitely like the best written
piece too of his as well
it's like the best of best visually and
the best written because it's just so
simple it's straightforward really moody
and it's it's all about that world
building you know it's like
the reason why it feels so real is
because so much effort went into making
all these different
parts feel real can we talk about that
we we
we talked with him yeah yeah yeah okay
yeah we uh we haven't seen the effects
arts react
kind of he skyped in um so that episode
is coming out is that this weekend or
the following weekend
is this this weekend this weekend
everyone if you're tuning in right when
this is a chunky episode
episode is dropping yeah it was a guest
episode we have a we had a guest come in
but we also
uh took a look at uh dynamo uh ian
hubert's
most recent short film and we chatted
with him about it and
one of the things i found really
interesting that he mentioned was that
he would write a scene and kind of like
start working on that scene
but then start working backwards he's
like okay so for all of this to make
sense
all these other things would need to be
in place for this scene to make sense
and then he starts working on that scene
both writing and and you know technical
uh and then once that's in place it's
like oh okay but now i need to make all
these things make sense and why
these things exist and it works
backwards so he basically wrote the film
in reverse
interesting which i found really
interesting because now it's like as it
keeps going everything
works you know you know i don't think i
don't think that really works so well
for more
traditionally narrative driven stuff but
for something that is so
visceral and dense and sci-fi and like
otherworldly it's like yeah that makes
that's probably a good call to like get
really simple
and rewind it what's great about it
though is that like every single shot
tells a
a different story you know like just the
mere existence of
random things like she's on the train
and she looks out and she sees a giant
crab
fighting people in an alleyway and
you're just like moving on
what yeah and then that comes back to
play with like the
like this is the big robot fighting the
giant crab when she goes get like the
taco burgers yeah but that was the other
thing he made this whole like huge
race sequence and fight scene and all
this stuff and
for the actual film he made it's just so
that it goes up on some tvs in the
background
wait was the what was that like the
hollow ball or what's that the hyperbole
somewhere but i was like specifically
watching the screens
to find it and i couldn't find it i mean
it was there
he said there's more of it though
that'll be in like the next piece that
he said will be released in four years
or whatever
yeah i guess uh it if you haven't seen
ian's new video
um you know it's it's
it's almost a one-man army tour de force
of like 3d work all done in blender but
that doesn't really
even matter so much is the fact that
it's just like artistically speaking
so rich and there's so much imagination
in every shot and so much craftsmanship
you know it's basically somebody making
a digital diorama
of this world that they've entirely made
up three years working on it
yeah well he did so many photo scans
like build everything yeah a lot of
photo scans but also photo modeling i
feel like he's kind of a pioneer of that
concept a little bit like it's not new
by any stretch of the imagination but
like
no one's really pushing it as far as he
is and that's the idea of like he'll
take a picture of the side of the
building
you know and he'll just project that
onto a plane and then be like all right
there's this gutter that's running down
the length of this picture here and
he'll like just kind of like make some
lines where that gutter is and extruded
outwards
and meanwhile the picture is still
projected onto this plane and he starts
just building out geometry next thing
you know you have like a fairly detailed
3d model of this picture that he took so
he can add lights to it and actually add
shadow to the rest of the shot and all
that stuff and it's a very
easy way to get a decent amount enough
detail in something without having to go
through and photo scanning something
right
you know it's uh so that's how he does a
lot of the more
detailed walls and and storefronts and
windows and stuff like that
he has this method for getting like
bedrooms and whatnot so he'll it's all
driven by maps
and he does all of that and then he just
has basically a random generator for
each window sourcing a different map for
for that
the contents of that window and it's
cool stuff something like
really so many smart like super smart
ways to
it's like that really modern version of
pulleys you know like the pulley let's
even like multiply your force
like what universe does with blender is
like the most
modern advanced high-tech version of
pulleys where he is
multiplying his creative force like
thousand-fold yeah and
and so he asked him about render times i
mean basically you have a 21-minute
short film that's completely
rendered so that probably took a long
time to render right and it's like well
he
he specifically set it up so that most
of the shots are outside
and i was like how what okay why does
that make and he's like
there are fewer bounces before the paths
terminate
because you have a bounce hitting this
that and then up into the sky in a way
as opposed to indoors where it hits
something hits the roof hits the ground
again hits the roof and just bounces out
and it takes a long time for that noise
to resolve out
whereas uh these more outdoor pieces um
render a lot quicker plus you gotta you
got like a 30 90. uh
recently ish uh and so he was saying
that
like there's only one shot in the entire
thing that was rendered in eevee
but the rest of it was all just cycle
spreader and he was getting about
20 seconds per frame which is good
really good for like
final quality around cycles is similar
to octane right more or less
okay more or less i i could not tell
where
uh the practical set ended and the cg
set
began and and yeah almost in a great
deal of that piece
because we yeah the style was very
consistent
yeah yeah style when we went to his shop
like you know he
you could tell like he's he's thinking
about every
little thing that is going into those
little sets that he has just for the
the close-ups and the the interactive
stuff um
and it's pretty cool to see how that he
was able to translate that
same style not only to the rest of the
image but then across
the the video as well and that was that
was like that was another thing that
really
i think he he pushed the envelope on and
that was the use
of of you know some something filmed
practically
whether it's not just a green screen
element but like a set and whatnot
and he would basically in include that
into the 3d geometry
of the scene and render it all out as
one it gives you a lot more control
over the camera and you get these really
smooth transitions from
like a fully cg shot and then going down
to this room to
transitioning into like the fully
practical shot yeah it's like
no one else is really doing that like
not even hollywood studios because it
requires that sort of top-down
thinking of the person doing the effects
is the one actually
doing the shot filming it and designing
it i feel like it's honestly only marvel
like it's anywhere close
to like that same cohesion
marvel yeah like because like there will
there will be sequences so it's like you
know there could be a real human
standing on the shoulder of the cg giant
here that moves across this real thing
here literally
you know yeah i mean it's like i guess i
mean they're doing it at scale like that
but i feel like
the way they're doing it is brute force
i feel like i feel like ian has figured
out the actual efficient formula yeah
like he's the mad scientist who's
discovered like the
the the unifying equation to all life
and he's just like oh yeah it's great
it's like you need force just perfect
grace
yeah yeah i'm glad he's i'm glad he's
though he's i mean it's a great example
of taking the tools that you have
and your creative style like there's no
way in practical
hollywood production that you could film
and then go back
and re-film or readjust the scene or you
know rewrite something even
to fit something that then came about as
a process of your creativity
um ren you do that a little bit i mean
we all do that a little bit but i think
when you
when you're making your videos
particularly too you you do go through a
bit of a process of
sort of reassessing where you came from
to that point and obviously there's a
ton of that in there yeah i mean like
for me it's like i'll
i'll first start by like writing a
script and and
getting that most of the way fleshed out
and then i'll start filming kind of in
chunks and and editing those trunks and
slowly
realizing okay i need to get this other
thing filmed uh which is different than
how i originally had it written
and so it really evolves over the course
of the production and so by the end of
the
video it gets uploaded it usually is a
little different from what i originally
wrote
right um actually that's a great segue
i'll talk about something i'm working on
okay we're talking about efficiency
right all right yeah it kind of seems
like the subject here a little wait
sorry i thought that was your secret to
like
something i'm working on is efficiency i
thought you're gonna go into like a
whole like
personal no [ __ ] that if i [ __ ] my
personal stuff
there's no personal things to talk about
real quick before we go into that i want
to finish one last thought with ian oh
yeah so we went to ian's house two years
ago
this month last month i guess and uh
i had totally forgotten that like when
we were there he was kind of you know
showing us some of these little mini
sets he made in this church that he
lives in
uh this cult church and at the time
uh he is not he's not in the culture
he's not called
the cult is gone but the building
remains and and
because he possessed he got it he got a
deal
yeah because of the cult situation
anyway uh and so like
this was around this so he didn't really
have much to show us he showed us like a
little bit of what he's working on but
meanwhile we're like i mean
that's cool looking i mean sweet we
don't really know what you're planning
on but yeah cool
and meanwhile this was also the same
time we came up with the boss town
dynamics idea
and and and doing that it was all like
like right at that
that time uh yeah so he was he was there
for the inception of the boss town video
a little bit too
yeah even though i think technically
that was like you guys at the pool table
in portland
yeah we got there yeah we were like
really close to cracking it
yeah it was one of those ideas it was on
the back
from the pool from the pool hall that's
when it
yeah it's just kind of kind of crazy
time
anyway sam efficiency so we're talking
about efficiency well i was okay so what
we're talking about here is like that
idea of like
okay you can what's the fastest way to
get to
your like result here from an artistic
standpoint and like trying to like
go big scale but do it really
streamlined so one
two three people can navigate this huge
thing here
um and so
i'm gonna talk about unreal engine again
obviously yeah but whatever but no but
last week was crazy because the unreal
engine 5 came out
remember this is a futurology podcast
unreal engine 5 came out
it's been officially termed a futurology
podcast
futurology or futurism but it's it's
pretty nice we'll know that in the
future
i'll look it up sorry it's unreal engine
five well no
it's crazy because it's really good but
the more i'm starting to realize like
every like
it's the future of filmmaking it's the
future of cg filmmaking
like there's plenty of other ways to get
like beautiful results using blender and
all this stuff
but you know when it comes to the
concept of
setting up your shots and rendering your
stuff out and stuff like that
everyone's using it at this point like
everyone i know
who is into filmmaking is generally
getting into it at this point
and it's pretty crazy um it's kind of
scary because it's definitely putting
the pressure to like
get really good at it because of how
powerful it is and how
how many other people see that potential
so you know definitely want to ride that
wave but
unreal five came out last week and it's
super special because
it solves two things that
well one one thing is something that all
cg
programs struggle with yeah and the
other
is just it's superficial but nice so the
first thing
the first thing it solves is um there's
this
thing that's really exciting it's called
like nanite that's in it
and the nanite engine is basically
a real-time way for the engine
to decimate the 3d models depending on
how close you are to them
what that means is it basically is like
all right
you have a super high detailed sculpted
model that's got like millions and
millions and millions millions of little
polygons you know
basically polygons for those out there
who are unfamiliar polygons
are the individual faces that
make up an object a cube for example
effectively has
uh technically 12 if you break it into
triangles
okay yeah but six but it is it's but
six polygons if they're square they're
quad
quad polygons so that's a great example
square
a cube has six of these now you take a
bust of a
crazy sculpture and you zoom in
like how many little tiny polygons are
going to make up that shape
so what it can do in real time is you
take these huge models
and normally that's really taxing for a
computer because it's
constantly computing these millions
and millions and millions of points and
polygons and faces and all that stuff
whereas now you can drag them into
unreal and it processes the model
and you can just like paste them
everywhere and like it's just
insane like there's no limitation on
your poly counts
as it moves away from the camera as it
moves away from the camera it's
optimizing the models
so that way you're not having to compute
all these tiny little individual faces
on every single model
so it's like it's like the marriage of
data structure science with like
rendering science exactly and like
technology's kind of been around but
it's been through like way more
primitive means where
for instance like say you're using like
octane
the way octane does it is rather than
basing it on distance if you want like a
lot of polygons in your scene
basically you tell octane hey look at my
model over here i want you to replicate
that a million times
but only when you start rendering never
never make it show up when i'm working
because that's going to murder my
computer
and so it takes the model loads it into
its memory and knows hey i'm supposed to
make a thousand replicas of this later
and it's able to do that a lot more
efficiently when it's not actually
trying to like
yeah because it's not storing it a
thousand times in memory it's not
storing it a thousand times over and
just displaying it
that's instancing which i feel like is a
little different i know that's what i'm
saying
that's these are like the primitive
approaches that have existed in the past
but this new approach hasn't existed
ever
almost anywhere like so but so like in
previously in games
and in game engines the way it worked
was you would have
like three to five different models
that were all more and more optimized
it's called level of detail
so basically when you're close to a
character they're at level of detail
zero and when they're in the far
distance they're level of detail five
and you could act you can actually line
the models up and go oh look they're
like
decreasing in quality like until it gets
to garbage
like playstation one graphics like
playstation one being it's okay because
it's really far away and in the screen
it's going to be this big yeah exactly
there's like one pixel per polygon so
this is basically
doing that to every model you give it in
real time and
it's pretty wild and so well the
craziest thing is that you literally do
like remember like you're saying like
look guys really far in the distance
it's a playstation 1 style model
where it's like the polygons are so
small it's only one pixel per polygon
it's like yes
what if the entire screen was one pixel
per polygon what if we could
automatically up res and d
res every model so that if you're up
close to it
it says high details where every pixel
is still on polygon and if it's far away
one pixel is still one polygon yeah well
it kind of that's that's nanite so what
this does is it basically allows you to
break the
the the status quo of what game engines
are used for which is usually
you optimize everything for a game
engine like you you
really are really careful with your
models and your texture maps
and all this stuff to make sure it's
taking up as less the least amount of
space possible right yeah the smallest
files this
because you don't want your load times
that's been the biggest difference
between like say like cinema 4d and and
a real-time engine is because it's like
it's all about that optimization when
you're doing something in post it's like
you don't have to worry about
optimization you worry about quality
max settings everything instead of
worrying about how much ram does the
xbox 360 have
yeah exactly uh how many textures can
that support in this room
okay so so if we're talking about our
like optimization goal posts here for
like
the most amount of crap your computer
can handle this just took the like the
goal post
and brought it like miles into the
distance like almost so far that i
i honestly don't know where it is
anymore like i don't know
yeah it's just like okay well how am i
going to make a chunky scene now like
how like
what's going to slow my scene down if
it's not going to be the actual 3d
models at this point it's going to be
all the other things like textures and
stuff like that but so you know what my
concern is about this
it's such an awesome technology it's
amazing that we can literally just drop
in a
giant 3d mesh of a canyon and it's like
it just works you don't have to worry
about optimizing it
i worry that you know human nature is to
be lazy
and so what i worry is gonna happen is
that the video games we play and spend
so much time
downloading is just gonna get worse
because now instead of making sure that
each level was under a certain file size
they're like well
screw it man make sure yeah i'm sure
that level's 90 gigabytes and we have
four of them
whatever yeah like our game i literally
worry that this technology is gonna make
it so that the games we're downloading
are gonna be like three to
five hundred gigabytes per game that's
gonna be already over a hundred
gigabytes that's gonna happen it's
something that happens it's gonna suck
the newest modern warfare was like 120.
that pain is only temporary because
things will only get faster i know
that's true you get bigger hard drives
you get faster internet
you know it will even really gonna be
downloading games
like that that longer call of duty
warzone is
400 gigabytes now or something like that
no it was under 200 i want to say it was
120 160 maybe
180 189 it's it's pretty ridiculous you
include all the the expansion
and they're not even using anything like
this so
anyway so that's kind of a huge deal
because basically it's like
all right we're talking about using it
for making linear content
uh you know like not games and i mean
both four games and four games you can
use what you would call
cinema quality models for which is
pretty dope
um also there's a brand new lighting
engine which is really cool and
yeah so why why did you why didn't i
talk about that just it has nice lights
i mean it's pretty sweet
it's really nice dude you dropped in
that fog thing and you're like this was
so hard to do in uefa
well why didn't nanite exist before
people weren't smart enough yet
i think nanite is literally cutting edge
technology right now i think
part of why it doesn't exist before is
memory um because
it's it's virtualized geometry so it's
basically loading your mesh into
like the ram on your gpu and you know
you need to be able to load a 20 million
polygon model into your memory
you just don't have to render it at 20
million polygons you know you can render
it
as polygons that's insane that's yeah
that's pretty heavy it is heavy
um none of us are thinking it's like
we're not used to that there's nothing
like there's something like that in
cinema 4d
you can't just like load in as many
models as you want and just be like ah
just
automatically de-rez them so you're
still running nice and smooth like
there's nothing like that you know which
suddenly
moves unreal into this category of its
own well like even still like
certain scenes that i have set up in
unreal like don't run in cinema 4d like
i can't
view them in cinema 4d like they just
even even when you take the textures off
and the lighting off and all that stuff
just you can't handle it because cinema
and like blender like
that's brute force it's like here's the
model you can edit it you can do it
anything you want with it but it's going
to render it in its entirety
even in the viewport even when it's just
a temp render and that's because the
meshes are too dense
well it's yeah it's just because it's
like oh you want me to render 20 million
polygons sure here's all 20 million
right now
like you zoom out you zoom out until the
model is one pixel tall and it's still
going like
we figured out where all 20 million
polygons are right here they're all in
this one tiny
we did 20 million calculations to figure
out right here we did the math
they're all in this one pixel you know
this pixel is the perfect average color
of all
20 million polygons yeah yeah exactly
um yeah for those of you who don't know
you're looking at pretty high detailed
photo scans of the dnd board from our
yes dragon show so yeah now to from hype
to like real world use um basically so
the last few months we're like
we shot the son of a dungeon show we're
trying to figure out how to do the live
action stuff and i'm like oh my god
we we just unlocked the technology to
use unreal
for all the cg in it rather than
rendering it out in blender or octane
basically we can bring these we we photo
scanned
all of the game tables so once again
millions polygons
in these huge photo scans of these
miniature environments
and you know there's they look really
good
sometimes they look a little weird and
janky because of their photo scans and
you know we're doing our best but
overall with the the new lighting engine
and then this nanite
engine it's like in your normal maps and
some fancy normal map
tweaks i'm doing like it's basically
it's like
it's it's comparable quality to just
rendering them out with a normal
renderer and like octane um and
so not only is that cool
but what's even cooler is we've been
trying to figure out hey how do we
film on a green screen and get 3d camera
data at the same time so that way we can
do this way
faster and we've been very seriously
considering using uh
the cam track ar application to do this
because it gives you
it records your phone's video
and a 3d camera with it at the same time
but with unreal's new business here it's
like well
we can just set up vive trackers on our
camera
do some fancy tweaks and then basically
have the camera data recorded
in unreal engine which is crazy
because imagine a day of shooting you've
got a green screen you got a vibe
tracker
cut cut record record record at the end
of your day you have a huge folder in
unreal engine
of all these sequences with your
recorded camera data in it
i deal you a synced time code and no
seriously with sync timecode and
everything yeah you're having to get a
special card yeah i got a special video
card that does gen lock between the
camera and unreal so the frames
fire at the same time and then literally
at the end of your day of green screen
shooting you literally just drag all
these recorded camera takes into a queue
hit go and you just literally walk away
and maybe come back like 20 minutes
later and you've got every single shot
from your entire day
rendered right there which is nuts yeah
we're looking at weeks of rendering
timing for you to throw that into octane
which is already
one of the fastest renderers on the
planet yeah well it brings it from like
15 to 20 seconds per frame
to like point
seconds per frame yeah you're getting
frames per second rather than seconds
we're getting frames per second instead
of seconds formula
[Laughter]
so it's pretty it's pretty mind-blowing
stuff um it's also important to note
that everyone's working on real-time
rendering engines like
octane oh toy uh they're working on
brigade
which we still haven't really seen too
much about but it's their real-time
counterpart
to octane it's supposed to work like
octane but it's real time but
so sam i'm sure the question in
everybody's minds is
sam why aren't you feeling it on the
mandalorian set why why not
volume well uh i'm not gonna lie we've
had people reach out to us
who have volume stages and they're like
hey come use it and
i've definitely got a lot of pressure
from everywhere for me i have been
repeatedly
trying to pressure himself let's do it
let's just do it and for me
i would much rather start with like a
smaller project where we don't have
dozens of shots counting on it
that said we're gonna go check it out
but we should just do it what's
why not well yeah first off the one
reason is
you don't have floors or ceilings
because you're in a real life
environment and if you want to do floors
you have to put dirt down
you have to deal with blending the dirt
to your screen and calibrating it so
you're
what you're saying is essentially you're
limited to any types of shot where you
can't see the feet and you can't be
looking you don't have any low angles
looking up at people it's pretty much
all just like
medium front-on shots you'd be a lot of
mediums and then also
i mean i haven't seen the screen but
sometimes these led stages
do have problems when you focus
the camera to the screen as in like i
want a shot of the environment
with people in the foreground sometimes
the the the screen will break down now
that is called
moire anytime you pull your phone out to
take a picture of your tv
that's amore don't worry
it's that weird like rainbow pattern you
get when you when you try to record a
screen
and that's because a screen all this uh
a tv screen a computer screen all it is
is just
an led array with really really really
tiny leds
yeah so yeah that's that's why there's
also also all sorts of things
um once again those volumes are great we
talked about
having to do vfx as pre-production you
have to do vfx as pre-production your
shots have to be final before you roll
the camera
and there's all sorts of things you need
i would say you need a larger team you
need a larger team to shoot it you need
multiple people there
operating the screen both from a
technical standpoint and a creative
standpoint too
you know what i mean like you need
someone who's just like a creative like
moving boxes around
kind of guy moving lights around all
that virtual gaffers and grips man
people are gonna be [ __ ] gaffing and
gripping in like vr
i mean we can't talk too much about it
but we got some cool stories no we
don't i was just saying right now yeah
we talked with this guy felix george she
works at happy mushroom they do a ton of
the
basically environmental is designed for
the mandalorian they shoot on the
volumes
that's exactly what they do they have
virtual location scouts in unreal engine
where him and like john favreau and then
the dp
and then some like virtual like set
decorators and virtual gaffers hang out
and they literally wear vr goggles and
they're all in different parts of the
united states yeah and they all hop in
the vr and they all just like walk
around these virtual sets
and and it looks like a normal location
scout except
it's just people with vr headsets you
see little heads bobbing around
that's it yeah so man and then last but
not least
why not a volume well when you just
record the camera data
we have the flexibility to still make
tweaks to the render and
make sure the lighting match is better
like the background needs to be on fire
here or you know i need
some bodies over here yeah like we can
make we can still go in and make the
tweaks necessary
on a per shot basis that said it'll
still be really close and
probably will use a lot of the shots but
i i still feel like even if it's not the
whole project even if it's just like
one scene we should shoot something
there it could potentially be something
for this
knockout i'm down for something that's
not this project if you come up with an
idea let's do it
but i viewed my mood your logic now sam
i'm seeing your logic now because at
first i was like well what we'll knock
out
30 of the shots if we film it on a
volume but
now i'm seeing like well with the with
the speed at which we can
set up and get the shots in our own
studio using
these tools it's also with the added
improvisation that you get
yeah from just being able to be like ah
let's let's do that again or we didn't
like that let's come back next day
and change it it does still require the
the
the workflow of having a green screen
your character spill suppression color
matching all that stuff
it's like it makes it easier though
because we can see the background as
we're filming it
and go like oh there's a red light over
there yeah you know
you know it'd be really baller so we
figured out how to use fusion and
davinci resolve because
remember the the unreal footage can be
time code synced
so you can literally have davinci
automatically have every track be a
multi-track with two video feeds
one is your green screen feed one is
your background feed already linked
together in your bin
you just pop it over to fusion you pull
a quick key
you can do anything else you want you're
done it's all rendering on the gpu
full utilization yeah that's pretty
sweet
theoretically and it's automatically all
synced up in the timeline theoretically
we're not there yet but a boy can dream
no well i mean
that's how it's going to be exported
whenever when we hit render on those
shots
they're going to be exported time code
and we'll we can sync the backgrounds
automatically to all the footage we
shoot
automatically jesus pretty rad that's
pretty dope sorry someone started
dragging chairs
so it's pretty sweet uh yeah i know
it's it's amazing it's pretty it's super
amazing
i can't stop thinking about it every
week it's just like oh i can't stop
doing it
you're waking up in the middle of the
night in cold sweats sam thinking about
what you can do next
yes i am thinking about it and i'm sorry
i swear to god before i leave on this
vacation i'm carving out like three
hours
to put mocap suits on to film this quiet
place with farts video
in unreal engine i finally watched that
how was it
a quiet place with farts you watched it
no no no no it's a movie that i'm the
original one we have i've been trying to
make this video for months
and this week is like oh we're shooting
these important videos every day
it's like i'm going on vacation in a
week and a half
and this movie's hot right now it's the
only movie in america
it's it's the apocalypse and one movie
finally came out that was good
and it's the only movie people are
watching i still haven't seen the second
one i loved the first one
perfect quiet place then you'll love
this video
i think we can do it just all like i've
got a great forced map
looks beautiful i got apocalypse
characters hey let's see
let's see when we can do this let me
look at the calendar like i think we
could honestly do it as like a half
day mocap session and it would be
tailored so that there's no
guns no objects it's just jokes and
funny faces
no interactions with characters and
physical props it's literally just
goofing around in mocap suits in a
beautiful forest environment and
having to fart we could probably but not
farting
we could probably because there's a
monster that can hear it
you could probably do it monday it'll be
the time of your life for whoever
helps make it nika do you want to talk
about what's happening tomorrow
sure and i think they'll take us out of
this podcast yeah to wrap things up
tomorrow i'm going to be doing a
daredevil stunt
i'm going to just making the jump making
the jump off the top of our building
onto a big pile of cardboard boxes with
an actual
stunt team supervising me and showing me
how to do a high fall
so i will be doing a high fall off the
roof of our building
and it's gonna be rad i can't wait make
sure you stretch man
yeah yeah do something do some yoga in
the morning
you're right actually because i'm a
freaking 35 year old man
make sure your emotion is good i'm i'm
very jealous i was actually thinking
about this last night and talking with
jenna about it i was just like
about like i should try to like
weasel my way into this to do it as well
and i was like
you have two broken buttons
and i realized yeah that's the worst i i
really can't do that and so like i'm in
my own head thinking about this and jen
and i are watching tv in bed and i get
out of bed
and i i get down on the ground into a
push-up position
and just go ah and i get back in bed and
jenna's just
looking at me like i'm literally insane
like what was that about i'm like don't
worry about it i was just seeing if i
could jump off a building
and the answer is absolutely not okay
okay no i'm sure i mean real talk i
wasn't actually going to try to
to like you know make it a thing but
part of me was like man that's so cool
what if i could do it
i was jealous of climbing left but lit
on fire oh yeah
okay we still got more there's the
getting squibbed up
getting scrubbed up would be really fun
say i might claim that i've heard i've
heard squibs hurt like hell
yeah they do
it depends where it depends where yeah
right right in the cheekbone
kind of scrub too yeah yeah
anyways i'm a little nervous i shouldn't
be but it means i'm respecting
the uh the situation but honestly it'll
be really fun and i'm looking forward to
it
i i really want to don't know what to
expect yeah no i mean but i really want
to
see you explore all these thoughts and
emotions
with the stunt coordinator because i'm
sure they're all thoughts that he's had
before he's known people to have
and i really want to i don't want to see
his perspective on on this yeah me too
i was like where does the thrill sinking
thrill seeking like you know adrenaline
junkie line cross with the i'm
professional and it shouldn't be about
the thrill it should be about just
yeah because i feel like the the clint
on fire video was a little bit more that
was pretty serious granted that was
serious it's fire reasonably so but i
feel like
the i don't know it would have been cool
to see a little bit more of the
exploration of the the enjoyment side of
that thing
yeah you know yeah we'll figure that out
tomorrow yeah well it's true i mean this
podcast probably isn't it's gonna be out
after that
so yeah i guess we'll find out how it
went
yeah all right oh also i mean real quick
before we go we have
we have to do it nico how's the mountain
bike
the man bike's so good i've rode it so
much memorial day weekend
all right everyone listen you gotta go
out and get electric mountain bikes
everybody real quick we gotta go out and
get them we did a ride on sunday
we went up to the top of verdugo and
nico was running super late and i
betrayed the one-wheel squad
yeah it was a little bit of a trail but
it was cool uh you're like i'll catch up
and i made the calls like
he is going to catch up let's go
everyone so we just left
and we were like halfway up the mountain
and niko's like i'm on my way
and by the time we got to the top he was
there yeah wow
it's real fast it's real fast tried
another exploration down the trail on
the mountain
and it got real sketch and we had to
turn around this wasn't with the
onewheel squad is uh
my with my buddy mike and mountain bikes
can take you to some gnarly places and
you gotta respect the mountain
because you can get stuck out there
without water if you're not careful
if your bike breaks down and you're five
miles away from civilization yeah
but we were okay oh yeah we were talking
about your bike sam
uh when was the last time it broke down
it's never like
completely broken down you'd have like a
little component break here and there
yeah well
for the first like six months basically
everything constantly went wrong with it
until i had gone through the entire
thing and
re-tightened everything uh so yeah
that's basically they ship it to you
with everything loose
apparently like i lost like caps for my
front axle
oh no i lost screws that held the pedals
in place
um i lost the the bearings for the pedal
system popped out at one point and the
gear fell off
yeah that's like saying the wheel fell
off your car while you're going down the
road
it's all close feels like that um
so yeah all sorts of little things that
are super sketchy
um and it's like i now at this point i
mean
i just before i ride the bike i just
look at everything i'm like is
everything here
and then i write it like a pre-flight
check yeah i can kind of do that a
little bit
but it's been working great since then i
haven't had i've
no maintenance in the last year have you
ever crashed on it
yes once how bad was it it was
um 10 out of 10 being
death and 0 out of 10 being hopping off
the bike and
not being injured at all it was about
like uh like a six
really well because i was going around
it was like right next to my house too i
was just going around a corner
cruising it's a blind turn i'm going
around the corner and um
car pulls up to a stop sign super fast
that i'm where i'm turning into
and so i hit the brakes and because
i'm still not used to dirt bike slash
motorcycle brake configurations
i leaned way too hard on the front brake
so both wheels locked up
and basically it's just the bike just
went down and i slid
and basically jacked my leg up and i had
i got like a you know i got road rash
all of it yeah but the bad part was that
it bumped my like pelvis bone
um and the and it in my i had like an
inflamed pelvis joint for like
two months afterwards that made it
really hard to walk i kind of remember
that yeah yeah
how long ago was that that was that was
last summer okay
so that that was that's the worst that's
happened but
that's why i i'm not turning the 50 mile
an hour mode on
because it's like like 28 is fine
it's fast enough yeah and it's just at
that threshold where i probably won't
die if i get
if i crash so you're right you're right
once i cross over that then it's like
ooh
here we go we're neck breaking back
breaking territory yeah
yeah it's like somebody pulls out in
front of you it's yeah
yeah that's true it does go up after
after 40 basically you're after 40 miles
an hour
yeah things go up pretty exponentially
yeah so
but other than that great time highly
recommend it e-bikes
i mean if you think about it when you're
riding a motorcycle you are a kinetic
battery yeah you you are you are
literally storing kinetic energy
in your soul and that energy can explode
like
a lipo battery
hell yeah so metal
all right are you singing a song about
uh kinetic batteries exploding
yeah man are you ready yeah
i had a kinetic battery in my soul
[Music]
i didn't know that it could explode
and it came around the corner
there was a car at a stop sign and it
it went kaboom
i got a connecticut battery
in my soul i don't
know i am loving this when it's
going to explode
yeah all right
thanks for listening everyone we'll see
you next week
next week you'll hear us in your earbuds
cause a three two one